Declarative memory is a broad term which can include both episodic and semantic
memory. An easy way to remember declarative memory, is that you declare or
communicate your memory to another. For example, in 1492 Columbus sailed the
ocean blue. That is a declarative tidbit that some of you may have learned in
school. Two other distinctions in the types of memory are explicit memory and
implicit memory. Some psychologists refer to declarative memory as a type of
explicit memory. Again, this is our ability to consciously recall facts and
events. So we would say in some cases, that semantic and episodic memories are
types of explicit memory. We're able to describe and recall events and things
that we've learned in the past. Now let's go take a closer look at implicit
memory.